I never expected to be sued as a doctor  and thinking of settling am I supposed  to do we want me to save rich suppose I  was one of your patients what do you  tell me I tell you to fight yeah and  find that body of the mother they're  gonna come looking for us I'll search  for two fugitives suspected bombs  robbery earlier this evening  [Music]  that him yeah that's him this is perfect  isolated remote  my brother already has your wife and get  your operating doc my brother guys I'm  gonna kill you  look who your daughter I'm gonna kill  your wife and I'm gonna kill your dad  are we gonna be okay  used to be the big dog in town  don't try anything I start cutting bite  on this  [Music]  we have to take control  I'm scared for you I promise  [Music]  what are you gonna do I'm gonna fight  him  [Music]  get out of here now  [Music]  and Tufts on a [ __ ] huh  [Music]  you  you